for the environment secretary george
eustis is here it's good to see you this
morning look this report was
commissioned by the home secretary does
that mean the government is going to act
on the recommendations
well obviously pretty patel will now
look at uh these recommendations but i
think you know this report does
highlight some differences between
police forces and i think in these sorts
of situations violence against women is
a serious problem domestic violence has
also been a problem for some time now
and what we really need to do is to
learn from those police forces that are
addressing this well and i think report
highlights that some of them are doing
far better than others
and that actually try and replicate
those approaches that uh that work in
parts of the country it's it it's not
purely a police issue though is it i
mean this report says three quarters of
domestic abuse cases are closed without
even a suspect being charged and not all
but some of that is down to to victims
sort of withdrawing the complaint if you
like i mean there's a wider societal
issue here isn't there yes well it is
and i know in devon and cornwall uh that
the police force where i come from we
have some real problems with uh domestic
violence in some of our communities and
actually often some of the things that
can work quite well are
um you know involvement to to help the
partners that get angry and get violent
and actually to try and and help you
know defuse and manage some of those
stressful situations in the home which
often are behind some of these things so
you get you know you can get those uh
those other sorts of interventions that
can help deal um with with problems of
domestic violence i mean i know there
there is already a scheme in place to
help sort of
children primary school children learn
about healthy relationships but if if
children are being brought up in a home
where there is
violence or aggression
can that can they be targeted in a way
to to make sure they don't get caught in
that spiral
well you know we have lots of family
support workers and and interventions
and obviously social services and local
authorities it's not just those that are
under a very close watch they also have
family support workers that try to do
this but you know a chaotic home
environment where there's lots of anger
lots of violence it isn't a great
environment for those children and there
are some good programs that i've seen
where you get interventions to try to
defuse those types of situations um get
both parents in that relationship to
you know to learn to sort of manage
their anger issues and that can actually
deal with some of the sort of lower
level um uh domestic violence of course
you then get still those very serious
cases and that's when the police do have
to drive it through and take a
prosecution forward yeah i mean in terms
of what the government can do to signal
its intent what about the istanbul
convention i mean that was an
international agreement to
to to come to
to sort of common standards in how we
deal with violence against women and
girls it was open for signatures in 2011
10 years ago 45 countries have signed
the uk still hasn't i mean do we need to
do that well look i think the fact that
pretty patel um you know commissioned
this report asked for this piece of work
shows the seriousness with which she
takes this issue
and i think what we really want is that
uh you know domestic policy response to
deal with this problem learn from those
police forces that are addressing uh the
problem and doing well and replicate
that in the others and i'm sure that's
exactly what priti patel will want to be
doing with police forces around the
country okay look we're going to have a
lot more on that throughout the course
of the morning but in the meantime can
we talk about
covid and travel as someone who's
finally going on a holiday next month
this is particularly interesting to me i
have to say what is happening are we
expecting an announcement on these sort
of pcr tests as you return to the uk is
that going to be happening today well my
understanding is no decisions have
actually been taken yet although i
understand there may be a meeting today
to review this we regularly
review those travel restrictions
obviously we took um a very important
step a bit earlier this summer when we
removed the need to quarantine for those
coming from ambulance countries that was
a really big step forward but we have
retained the need for testing and that's
really so that we can pick up any
variance of concern through that pcr
test but look i know um that this has
been raised by the travel industry that
they think some of that testing may be
unnecessary may be onerous the
government will be uh listening to that
and obviously the uh the coveted
subcommittee of cabinet that uh decides
these things will be considering that
probably later today i mean there seems
to be a pretty clear indication and i
don't quite know where it all comes from
but
lots of rumors flying about that pcrs
could be scrapped for lateral tests
which obviously are cheaper and easier
is is that something you've heard
well um i haven't heard because i'm not
on that particular subcommittee that
deals with this and obviously you know
they will want to consider all of the
evidence before taking a final decision
i mean the rationale for the pcr test
is that you can do sort of genome
sequencing of variants and you can
therefore
detect possible variants of concern and
the the difficulty with the lateral flow
test although it's cheaper and it's
simpler to do is is that it's not able
to pick up those variants so that's the
rationale and been the rationale so far
for making sure that we keep some of
that pcr testing in place
but when you look at the situation that
our our code infection rates are higher
than they are in a lot of mainland
europe particularly even though our
vaccination system is is is pretty good
um
but with that in mind i mean it it does
raise questions doesn't mean even the
health secretary made the point that he
thought this this need to be needed to
be seriously looked at
uh yes so i did say that we would um you
know look at this he doesn't want to
have unnecessary testing in place but i
think he also recognizes the value of
those pcr tests so you know there's a
there's a discussion to be had about
this as i said we've already made that
big step forward of ending the need for
quarantine from people returning from
ambulance countries that was a game
changer if we can do uh further
refinements on testing then obviously
we'll look at that to you know reduce
those burdens but we do um also need to
be you know mindful and vigilant against
new variants coming in we have done
incredibly well with our vaccination
program it enabled us to open things up
again and the the vaccination that we've
done is preventing those
hospitalizations and keeping that
mortality right down uh but we what we
don't want is to end up with a variant
that can evade the vaccine and that's
what we've got to remain vigilant about
it it is reaching a critical point
though for the travel industry isn't it
obviously it's been a dreadful couple of
years and we're now easing off into a
sort of quieter season so
if there was ever a right time to do
this it's now isn't it well look it's
been a very very uh difficult time for
the travel industry we absolutely
recognize that that's why we've done all
we can to
you know have those easements in place
reduce the restrictions as quickly as we
can
but you know arguably the biggest threat
to the travel industry is that we do get
another variant that manages to get
around the vaccine that the vaccine
can't deal with then we're into another
full lockdown and that's not what we
want that's why we've taken this
cautiously step by step because we want
each step we take to be irreversible i
know you're making us wait for any
announcement and that's fair enough to
to an extent but there is also talk of
scrapping the amber and just having red
and green now
that may seem sensible to a lot of
people the problem is that's following
on from what the labour party was
demanding
months ago
well i actually still think there's the
rationale
for amber and has been because we have
gained by having those pcr tests on
people returning because it has given us
extra protection extra surveillance
against those potential variants of
concern the redless countries remain uh
the highest risks but but we think
there's been that uh rationale for the
ambulance and by the way i'm not waiting
for the announcement i'm waiting for a
decision that i understand has not yet
been discussed and perhaps will be later
today okay um can we talk reshuffle
because obviously you've kept your job
uh which is very good news to you and
you've got the first meeting of the new
cabinet what about nine o'clock this
morning something like that yes um
what has the prime minister been trying
to achieve with this reshuffle because
he i mean he certainly hasn't created a
cabinet with a sort of single ideology
has he
uh no but i i think you know the
conservative party has always been a
broad church and any government any
prime minister will want to bring
together a cabinet of all the talents
and we'll want to make sure you've got
lots of different perspectives
represented that's how you get a good
debate in cabinet and that's exactly
what he's done and i think really what
he's uh seeking to do with this
reshuffle is get the team in place that
he wants to you know deliver a post
pandemic the recovery of our country to
build back better build back greener get
our economy going again
get wages up get people in better paid
jobs improve skills and this is his big
focus over the
remaining part of this parliament and
he's assembled his team to do that so i
mean very much what a focus on on a
domestic agenda and
and within that then how big a role is
michael gove going to play housing
secretary
and yet the the sort of leveling up
agenda seems to fall within his remit
now that's
going to be crucial moving forward for
the conservatives isn't it yes well look
i worked very closely with michael gove
when he was in my own department in in
defra when i was a minister there
he's got a formidable intellect um very
good at problem solving very good at
getting to grip with detail quickly um
there are some very important reforms
we've got on planning where we want to
simplify the process but make sure we've
got the right uh protections in place
make sure we build aesthetically uh you
know beautiful housing around the
country and not the usual sort of
identicate things that we've become used
to so i think he's in a very uh good
position to take those reforms forward
and also
he retains that brief around uh you know
the wider uk and that's a passion of his
but is it right that at this point in in
a government cycle that we are i mean it
seems pretty clear you're gearing up for
the next election that could be 2023 it
could be 2024. oliver dowden seems to be
pretty convinced that now you need to
get on the election footing is that your
understanding well look um i think what
oliver dowden said is we should be ready
for an election whenever it might come
um and that's what every party chairman
will always do their task is to make
sure that the party is ready but for
cabinet as a whole uh our priority is to
deliver we've still got uh several years
left of this parliament and we've got a
lot that we want to achieve there's
going to be a lot of challenges that
need addressing uh post this pandemic
that's going to be our absolute focus
and can you do that within even if
you've got sort of two or three years
left can you deliver everything that was
promised back in 2019
well look the um you know the pandemic
wasn't in anyone's manifesto as the
prime minister said so we've already had
to take uh difficult but necessary and
right choices on things like the the
health and social care levy that we've
introduced to to deal with that huge
backlog in the nhs and also to get our
social care system on a
a firmer more viable footing so we're
willing to take those uh difficult
decisions but yeah we also want to crack
on and deliver many of those things that
were in our manifesto delivering for the
environment which is a very much a focus
for me with an environment bill going
through now improving uh our approach on
things like animal welfare so i've got
uh bills like that that i'm focusing on
other departments will have their own
priorities that will also manifest their
commitments okay minister good to talk
to you thank you thank you very much